feel like i'm struggling to breathe it
blew my [ __ ] mind
i don't know who's dick i've gotta suck
they get [ __ ] respect around here
true geordie went through incredible
adversity to get to where he is today
depression anxiety and he's one of the
few people
that's willing to tell you about it the
ego was just going
[ __ ] crazy i'm the man all the worst
parts of me amplified it was it was
better than a drug it was better than
anything
it was like wow i would have carried on
doing that probably if i hadn't have had
a moment of like boom
it just felt like everything i've been
building who had been like
really like [ __ ] up i know i needed
humbled
but it was brutal i literally wanted to
kill myself like you know i really
really did
when you love someone more than anything
else in this world
that matters more than anything and
where others would have capitalized on a
sub story
she was far too precious for me to
share she was mine she wasn't there for
anyone else was just my mom and i miss
her every [ __ ] day bro but once you
give it
there's no taking it back the day i
don't need money anymore
that's going to be a scary day for the
rest of the internet i don't i don't
want to let the fans down and i don't
want to stop doing what they
love me for but
true geordi brian he's one of the real
pioneers in the youtube space he runs
one of the biggest football shows the
biggest podcast the biggest boxing shows
and much much more but he is at heart
not the guy you see on screen he is a
gentle giant
one born in a council estate who went
through incredible
adversity to get to where he is today
billions of views
his conversations seem to sway cultural
conversation
but he's still not getting what he
deserves in his opinion
and in mine when you see true geordie
what you see is this big
six foot five guy with tattoos and huge
muscles but when you peel the layers
back you find the
total opposite you find a small kid in
there
one that's still living in the council
estate in his mind
and one that's missing his mother after
her tragic death a few years ago
he's been to rock bottom depression
anxiety suicidal ideation
and he's one of the few people that's
willing to tell you about it
and tell you about it with full honesty
and vulnerability
i've known brian a long time and i've
been so fascinated by him because he
appears to be this contradiction he
appears to be someone that does not give
a f but at the same time he's incredibly
incredibly sensitive to me he's the
ultimate reminder that we are all a
contradiction
and that you should never judge a book
by its cover what you're going to hear
today is some stories that brian has
never told
stories that will move you some that
might move you to tears
but also stories that will inspire you
and teach you some important life
lessons about what it really is to be a
human being
scars and all without further ado i'm
stephen bartlett
and this is the direva ceo i hope
nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
how would you define and describe the
rise of true geordie and when i say that
i'm talking about
take me to the early days okay the stuff
that made you
who you are today um
i'm an opportunistic person i i when i
see a tiny little like thing i just blow
it open straight away so like
uh the first um thing that happened to
me was
i made a random run about a footballer
that went
viral didn't really do youtube at all
just boom
and then loads of people seeing it in
the northeast it was like
this crazy son of a [ __ ] because no one
really
did stuff like that then i was one of
the first guys to do a football run
i want to go back further what really
yeah what further
in how well i want to know the the the
insecure kid on the council estate all
right okay
um kind of sensitive inside but had to
act
sort of tough because if you didn't
you would be [ __ ] up like you know on
the estate like
like my shed once got burned down like
set on fire
just by some kids just cause it was a
shed
and it was there you know like you had
to carry yourself in a certain way
because all of our dads were in prison
all of our dads
like it was like weird you know what i
mean so we were sort of raising each
other
and like i was like a milk kid at school
just because i could like
drink extra milk and that it like dinner
time and stuff
and i was smart obviously i'm a smart
guy but like
i was looked upon as like a nightmare
like my
when i was 10 years old my teacher told
my mother a parent's evening
she went you can just tell when some of
them are destined for prison can't you
but like she worded it like that you
know what i mean and my mom's like i
know exactly what you're saying but like
it was because i hated her she didn't
understand me to get me she talked down
to me
so being talked down to that really
pisses me off even at a ten-year-old age
like i didn't like that
you can win me over and i'll be i'll be
brilliant for you but just respect this
ask me don't tell me you know like even
and i know that's like a naive way to
look at the world but i was 10 and i
just had a chip on my shoulder
and um yeah didn't like authority
um and but i always was quite
like a little bit competitive uh i
remember like
there was a couple of kids like just
little random memories i have of like
i was fighting all the time but like i
remember i always thought of myself as
one of the smarter lads and
there was this thing about like some
sort of school day
where they selected like the brightest
boys and the brightest girls and i
wasn't selected my mom were thinking
i'm smarter than them you know like but
i couldn't prove it or whatever or i
don't know i was i was in
detention a lot i got thrown out of
school multiple times
once for pissing on the uh the school
teacher's lounge window and telling the
[ __ ] off when i was eight years
old
one for fighting uh just
just white like rebellious you know but
like
but with a brain and i just needed to
like find something uh
what caused you to be that rebellious
eight-year-old kid i think it's genetic
a little bit my dad was a rebellious man
very much so my mom not at all my mom
loving caring kind
mother teresa my dad uh like a punk
rocker who wanted it
he like he did mad [ __ ] when he was at
school like he took the whole school on
strike once just because he didn't like
the teacher and like
he was known for like he was thrown out
of schools for like beating teachers up
and stuff like that because when he was
like 14
violence was his life you know what i
mean do you actually think it's genetic
i think that um
yeah i think i think part of what makes
me aggressive
is my genetic yeah because even the look
i get on my face when i'm about to fight
is identical to the look my dad gets
like it's that
that switch you know what i mean so
i'm lucky that i've got it diluted with
the kindness of my mother
and i finally managed to channel the
aggression into
later on in life into like
focus and drive into the good stuff you
know what i mean by the time i didn't
i was overwhelmed with whatever the [ __ ]
was going on in my head i didn't really
know what the hell it was
i had joe wick sat here you know the
body coach guy and he um
he told me about his mum and his dad and
his mum was very very caring and
compassionate and his dad would punch
dole
um holes in the door yeah every day and
you know was
violent and abusive and joe wicks has
come out as
really really compassionate and kind i
don't know if you know him
personally but no even you know during
the during the lockdown people
saw him doing pee with joe and dancing
and doing his room and stuff was that
the the guy
yeah popular for the pa stuff yeah but
he was
he was crying and he was he was ups
deeply upset that there was a lockdown
because it would hurt other people
one of the most compassionate people
i've ever had met and his dad was
from his account very very um aggressive
so i've always wondered about these
generational cycles
whether it's you know i think it's
different for different people
i personally i believe that there's a
cocktail in me that's
a real weird mixture of a self-obsessed
arrogant showman who was my dad
bodybuilder hard man went to prison
fighter
and then a woman who worked like looking
after people
very caring compassionate loving
charitable generous you know all the
good things
and i'm not saying my dad can't be good
in any way but it was just to a very
polar opposite people
and for me i i see that come out in me
and there's and there's there i believe
in both genetic and uh like the
sociology side of it as well
even any brothers or sisters i've got a
half sister from my dad's side
yeah do you think it makes a difference
being an only child
of sorts uh yeah yeah definitely me and
lawrence have had a few
conversations he's an only child too um
and i think it does make you just live
in your own head a little bit
you know and it makes you like i have
times where if i spend too much time
around people i'm like
i need a [ __ ] break from this like i
want to be on my own and just listen to
music for a bit
i heard you say this thing um i heard
you say that people who live in their
own heads and
think the most i struggle the most
they're they're the ones who are more
susceptible to depression i would say
yeah
do you want to come in and watch this
podcast live from behind the scenes
if you do all you have to do is hit the
subscribe button and now that the world
has opened up
you'll be behind the scenes as many of
our subscribers have been i can't wait
to meet you
so take me through the rise so we i know
every it's well documented
how you became to be a youtuber yeah
apologies i'm just used to rehearsal
yeah i know yeah and i i don't you're
the same yeah you you tell the story a
lot
that he just rolls up and it loses its
emotion because i've said it that many
times but yeah so you
you rose as a youtuber i want to get to
the point where we you know money starts
coming in
because for me 23 24 years old when
money started coming in
i was going to every night club in the
weekend and getting five bottles of don
perry on
and i was trying to fill some kind of
gap in me
and from what i saw in your videos you
did a similar following
i'd had a bit of money before youtube
because i was working offshore on the
oil rigs
doing a dfc diving so that was good
money i was earning about ten thousand
pound a month doing that
and that was a bit of a wild lifestyle
because i was young i was working class
i was surrounded by
men who were military men who wanted to
go out
beat men up and [ __ ] women and take
drugs and and get drunk you know so i
was surrounded they were my male role
models
like you know so it was a crazy
lifestyle that so that was kind of
partly me getting
raised by these [ __ ] men around me
and then obviously um when i found
youtube it was like a rebirth of like
oh um like i went in
it's a long story but i went into a bit
of depression coming out of diving and
not knowing what the [ __ ] i wanted to do
with my life because i didn't know like
i knew i didn't want to be a diver
anymore i knew i was done with that
and when i found youtube it felt like a
little uh window of hope and then
obviously that took off and once i
i started getting money yeah it was like
okay i've
i made it because i i basically gave up
on money i chose youtube
as a path to happiness that was the idea
was
give up the money forget that you're not
happy doing that job i'd rather make
minimum wage doing videos
than make six figures doing diving
so i went on that path and then i it
dawned on me
oh i'm gonna make more money doing this
actually once once i was in the
thousands a month it was a bit
of a oh [ __ ] like okay
how do i handle this and i thought i had
a good handle on it like
it was little stuff at first new car
move move house
better place and all that and then once
i came to london that was when it really
went tits up to be honest with you i
just started spending money like crazy
i bought three new cars in the space of
about 18 months
um not all together one after the other
sort of thing but like
um i was able to get things that i never
dreamt possible and that was the moment
of like
oh i can have this like my favorite car
ever wow
uh bought an audi r8 first that went
fast nice nice
blue audio beautiful then i swapped that
for a mclaren
uh which they had the convertible the
roof come down i thought i was the dog's
bollocks and that
especially a guy like me like what the
[ __ ] am i doing in a mclaren you know
it'll look ridiculous yeah yeah
cause i'm so huge and then i swapped
that for a bentley
um gt sixly um the continental
um white leather interior oh gorgeous
all black wheels black everything else
black and white there's this bit we
talked about when you leave diving
and you kind of lose your orientation
and that gives you minor depression
which
seems to be so common in people when
they
they lose their purpose and i mean i had
tom bloomfield's out here as well it was
very similar
they lose their sense of purpose in life
their direction they feel that
disorientation
they feel the depression then you went
after something that you thought would
give you like intrinsic internal joy
and then it becomes a career and i read
this study which i found fascinating
that
in um in in psychology if they give
someone
a game that they enjoy and they play it
they enjoy it
and then if they then give them the same
game and pay them
to do it they lose joy so when you start
paying someone to do something that they
once did for the sheer fun of it
they lose the fulfillment they're
getting from it i've seen it in boxing
and stuff like that a lot like
the passion goes once it becomes
monetary and
obligatory you have to do it it's not
i'm getting up and doing this
passion now and but
i've never lost the passion for video
making that's still there i love it
um but um yeah i lost my way like
this whole thing of doing something for
the right reasons
because i'd never experienced a kind of
money before
i i remember like driving that audi the
first one the audi r8 when i drove that
off the parking lot
that was a moment of like what the [ __ ]
like it just blew my mind you know what
i mean the fact that i was able
to drive a car with um
it was worth a hundred thousand pound
and i paid for it in cash you didn't
really boom yeah i was like
and uh and i remember just driving it
and it was
it honestly i don't regret it because
even though it was a complete waste of
[ __ ] money
and i wasted even more money swapping it
for the other two cars
it was a real healthy lesson to learn
and get out my system
but it was like a drug you know it was
it was better than a drug it was better
than anything it was like
wow this is like for me i don't know
what it is about
fast cars and they look nice and the way
you feel when you're in
just makes you feel like a [ __ ] movie
star or something you know um
especially coming from a place where
people
set fire at your shed because there was
a shed you know
like nobody had a nice car where i came
from you know it wasn't
people didn't even have like a mercedes
or bmw
let alone a supercar so that was
mind-blowing
you know what i mean and they just it
was too much for us just was
and a lot a lot my ego was just going
[ __ ] crazy
you know what i mean like i'm the man
you know all the worst parts of me just
amplified
there's there must be a reason why you
got you traded it in so many times
though right i was addicted to that
feeling the new the new [ __ ]
that that was the oh but but what if oh
and then i seen the mclaren
i remember driving it into the [ __ ]
this super car place
i looked at the mclaren i looked back at
me already i was like i don't really and
then i just kept looking at the camera
it's new that's the new [ __ ] the new
hotness i know
you know it's ridiculous just absolutely
idiotic
never ends yeah i would have carried on
i would have carried on
doing that probably if i hadn't have had
a moment of like
that boom you know what i mean
what are you doing mate you know health
health life's good at that
give you a good slap around the head
when you need it and i really needed it
you know what i mean because everything
that a man does when he's from nothing
like all these rappers you know i was
doing the same thing like
spunk money up the wall buy pointless
jewelry clothes
[ __ ] like that treating people the
wrong way
treating myself the wrong way not
looking after myself or piled away
or i think i just skipped like the good
years to elvis at the end do you know
what i mean like i just went
full throttle um so yeah you said
boom oh yeah yeah so i had a bit of a
moment where everything was just you
know came crashing down there was
um a lot of people know there was the
dms but also in the same week
there was the um the loss of a huge deal
um which for anybody that doesn't know
the dms some somebody leaked some dm's
yeah yeah somebody had sexual dms that
were out there
um and uh me being the crazy wild
bastard that i was at that moment
you know drinking a lot just doing all
sorts just [ __ ]
lost my way and then in the same week i
also had
a deal that was on the table that was
pretty much negotiated done
sign seal delivered which would have
secured
my financial future for the next two
years with a huge
company big betting company
multi-million pound deal
it wasn't it wasn't just one you know
what i mean it was the deal
um and they had hired a new guy who
thought
he knew better than the last guy um
and he i think he just like didn't like
me
he also i think it was partly like you
don't want to carry on
the work of the guy who used to have
your job so he
he was trying to find any reason he
could to um
you know [ __ ] it up and you know he did
what he did we got to a point where i
was like
are you going to do the deal or not me
like and there was um
i can't go with the specifics because i
agreed to like keep it
you know respectful like but there were
some things asked of me which were just
outrageous and um we we couldn't move on
basically
and i'm i'm very glad i didn't because
otherwise
everything i now have
it might it might not have ended up that
way do you know what i mean
when you're put in a position where do
you want to
do you want to keep your ownership of
things or or not you know what i mean so
but yeah that was a devastating blow and
then obviously having
people laughing at you for sexual dms
and stuff when
you know it was i was drunk as [ __ ] at
the time and it was just a stupid moment
but
regardless you know knowing that there's
just such little compassion out there
for you when you're having a
awful time it really it it took me
i got from as high as i was it took us
as low as possible
in that moment of like no one cares
everything you've worked hard for you
now don't
have i'd literally agree the tenancy
agreement on my flat
for two years on the basis that this was
all going to be saying
so i'm like what the [ __ ] do i do now
you know what i mean so
and then i was hit with a tax bill that
was
way more than i could handle as well
because in my head it's like
got the cash come in and got the tax
bill paid off and don't worry about it
so everything that could go wrong went
wrong
and um you know i know i needed humbled
but it was brutal that was and i know it
might sound to some people like out
there like
oh uh or poor pitiful you know
white boy problems and [ __ ] like that
but it
i literally wanted to kill myself like
you know i really really did because
it it was just too much even for me like
and i'm a pretty tough person it was
just
it was awful like the level of abuse and
ridicule i got online and and the
financial mess i was in
it just felt like everything i'd been
building had been like
really like [ __ ] up and uh
yeah it was even just talking about now
it's hard to to say
do you know what i mean because it was
bad it was awful um so that left me
in a really really low place
the people online would have had no idea
because i i remember watching that play
out from afar
and it was just online it was just kind
of jokes and well what you have to
remember is they didn't know i'd lost a
multi-million pound deal
yes they didn't know i had a six-figure
tax bill to pay
yes so that's happening behind the
scenes
and that happened before yeah before the
dm so then the dms happened as well
the icing on the cake was the dms right
if it was just one or the other
you could say maybe but when you're
financially [ __ ]
and you're also trending on twitter
being called
i'm not even going to say the words but
you know the things people say about gay
people that aren't to hurt them the
things people
you know you should go and do this you
should you know and
people love to kick people on the way
down but what they especially love and
this is the difference is
if you're a vulnerable person publicly
you're seen to be
i don't know let let's say you're you're
seen to be in some sort of subculture
that people view
in a way that's like oh poor them i hope
they're all right i'm a
big strong alpha male i look tough i
look like i can handle all the ridicule
in the world
um brush cockney you're like you know
so they people probably didn't think
you know like and also when you're a man
you don't get sympathy the way women get
sympathy when they go through revenge
porn or anything like that
it's not looked upon the same and i just
had to sort of think about it and take
and go
yeah this isn't fair but life isn't fair
so what the [ __ ] do you expect brian
like you know
um so i drank a lot of whiskey
and smoked a lot of weed that week if
i'm on a sweetie you know what's so
funny
i remember i remember seeing it trending
i thought i'd go on his
brian's account and see what he said
about it yeah nothing
silence yeah yeah and that for me was
really surprising
oh yeah yeah i think a lot of people
thought that actually but
i even in the chaos
i act quite cerebrally
i can be quite reptilian when i need to
be to get myself out of a
you see in diving for example in the
moment of panic
in that moment of like i could [ __ ]
die here i've been in those situations
if i don't act
smart i'm in a [ __ ] situation yeah
i gotta use i've gotta pull my knife
i'll cut this rope do this dude
i'm used to thinking like in that way
you know so
i just thought i'm gonna i'm just gonna
say nothing
i'm gonna have it have a have a night to
think about this just just think about
how i was i felt awful
i was wrong but i knew i wasn't going to
give up but even though i wanted to kill
myself i also thought
that weirdly i think all the the [ __ ]
sort of
it gave me something to resist do you
know what i mean it give me because i'm
a fighter in my heart so i was like nah
[ __ ] you um so um
within a day i was like okay this is how
we're gonna do this i'm gonna get
the two best piss take as i know and i'm
gonna get them to rip the piss out of me
make everyone feel like it's over and
done with now because the minute you
acknowledge it laugh it off and show
that you're not frightened
people will get bored move on to
something else and they'll scratch the
itch of saying because what they really
want me to do is self-destruct
but if i show i'm brave they'll respect
that and then move on
what they don't realize is i was pretty
[ __ ] drunk during that whole episode
really like i was it was we were
recording 11am i was on the whiskey
like i had like [ __ ] two massive
glasses full of whiskey straight
and then i was like right let's do this
and like because i knew they were going
to be brutal but i said you have to be
you have to just say every worse thing
because then people leave me the [ __ ]
alone
and then i'll really get on with my
depression then do you know what i mean
so that's how i was like
kind of like sensible
in planning out my own self-destruction
yeah it's very weird and i've spoken to
other people
about this when they've been in similar
situations like when logan went through
his thing
and he was like yeah see him i just uh
drank a lot and smoked a lot that was
that was that was what we both did like
you know
so yeah so that after that happened i
then had to um
okay where do we go from here then um
and i had a production company who were
partnered with us at the time
who agreed that they would carry the
cost to the kickoff
while we were looking for another
sponsor so that was very kind of them
shout out to pt knows who he is and
um we don't get me wrong
those costs have to be paid back at some
point so every show
is x amount of money every single fee
you know and this is the thing that
people forget i've probably got the
biggest crew on youtube
really so there's like 15 people every
show who need paid and every every
single time we do a kickoff show
that cost was building my my tax wasn't
going anywhere
i needed a [ __ ] sponsor big time um
so that was it was a bad time you know
what i mean a lot of pressure
i think that was the thing pressure i
felt it from every angle
you know how does how does that impact
other areas of your life i've heard you
talk about the impact it had on your
sleep
which i think is something people don't
think about enough because i think sleep
is probably the foundation of your mood
how you make decisions and everything in
between so
uh probably um
[Music]
i still haven't quite mastered that i
think that's the thing that
i think partly it's because when you
have your own business there's not
enough hours in the day so you're always
like
late night being like what else can we
do what else can we do so i'm [ __ ] at
sleeping
and like as soon as i wake up by the
time i've made the toilet for a piss i'm
thinking about what we need to do
like so that's part of it um but yeah
i drank myself to sleep to a point where
i was more collapsing rather than
sleeping you know and uh it was awful
like
i'm gonna play like just because these
are the questions that come to mind
you're drinking yourself to sleep but
you're a smart guy you know that that's
not good oh yeah yeah
but but at that point i cared more about
uh it was like almost like it was like a
mathematical equation it's like what
what is more important right now me
being like i didn't care about myself
i just thought get through the days
because
so my mom died right this is totally
exciting um previously to that and i
remembered when i got through that
i did a similar thing where i would just
i drank myself
to sleep for about a month at least and
i knew
if i could just get a few weeks under my
belt no matter how i got through it
it would be easier so i just had to get
to that point
and i think i'm not recommending this
by the way but few people will go
through the kind of week i went through
so luckily it won't be necessary but
sometimes
you've just got to put distance between
you and the event
and daylight will slowly become uh
seeable i'm not saying it was a good
idea yeah
yeah this is this is yeah it doesn't it
sounds like kind of
look good on the movie yeah i can
imagine yeah it for me
because if those issues aren't ever
properly addressed
then they kind of re-emerge or they say
so
i hear you but there's a time and a
place
and right in the aftermath isn't always
the best time to go and go
right let's let's figure out what went
wrong here it was
emotionally so distressing i just
thought
i am gonna [ __ ] every every waking
moment was
they're all like the the whole thing the
finances the tweet that the all this
[ __ ]
i couldn't
i couldn't address it at that point i
couldn't think about it at that point i
couldn't
work out what had gone wrong or all of
that i just thought get a [ __ ]
sponsor
keep doing the shows drink yourself to
sleep if you have to just get a [ __ ]
sponsor
keep the money coming in because right
now without money
you're you're [ __ ] so [ __ ] like i'm
homeless
you know i mean like the amount of bills
that were crewing up and the amount of
money i had
i was going to end up like i was like i
might end up
[ __ ] wherever you know what i mean
like
so it really wasn't about oh let's go
and work through my problems it was like
let's put some [ __ ] money
in the uh bank here was there one day
through that period which you remember
as being the most
agonizing one particular day
every day every single day was just as
bad as it was like when my mom died that
was what it reminded me of it was like i
had died almost like
every day i'd wake up so when my mom
died i remember when i'd wake up i'd go
oh and it was that first moment when
your eyes went
and you go oh it's real it actually
happened
and that's the moment where when when my
life had ended
it was that moment of when i'd first
wake up i'd go oh it's it's real it's
real
and then i'd have to get up and face the
day
you know what i mean and just try and
block it out when i'd go outside
i wore a cap i'd try everything i could
to to hide who i was because i felt
ashamed
that i was the dm guy or i used to think
of myself as like
a great podcaster someone who had
changed his life
brought himself from and now i was like
being like
shamed laughed at all of that [ __ ] so i
just felt
so like humiliated you know what i mean
i just didn't feel like me anymore
when you said you woke up and you the
first couple of seconds you thought it's
real
yeah does that mean that your sleep was
a place of peace
a place of escapism uh
yeah yeah yeah i'm asking this question
because tom bloomfield from monzo sat
there and he talks about being anxious
and depressed for about two years
and he said when i'd wake and he
literally said he was here last week he
said when i woke up
for two or three seconds i didn't know
who i was or where i was those were the
best and then he said
it would just come crashing back down no
so the best time
was when i was drunk before i went to
sleep
that was the point where i really
enjoyed it because i was like oh it's
like i'm not even here
you know what i mean so that was the
best time because
then nothing felt i couldn't feel
anything you know what i mean
that was ideal that's why i kept going
back there every night
but i wasn't an alcoholic or anything it
was that feeling that i was chasing the
i don't feel pain numbness yeah that was
the good bit
when your mother passed away you didn't
talk about it
no no i mean youtube's a shitty place
isn't it
it's a horror like as i found out the
hard way you know so
um and also she's just precious to me so
i
uh i keep it to myself always um i keep
hurting myself always i've only talked
about once
online and that was the rebuild
yeah and even in even in that video
which i watched twice
um i still had no idea when it had when
it happened
yeah yeah because i was trying to
pinpoint if there was like
a change in you or if it was during your
youtube career at the height of your
youtube career before
and and i thought it was you know for a
guy that does really pour it out on the
internet and i've seen you you
know when the logan paul incident
happened i watched that video and you
were
pouring out your heart in a way that was
just
remarkably vulnerable and that was just
a secret
yeah but it's like um
is that what i said earlier i can be
quite cerebral when i have to be and i
can make decisions when i have to be
pardon me for me own my own sake and
here's the thing when you love someone
more than anything else in this world
that matters more than anything and
where others would have capitalized on a
sub story
she was far too precious for me to
share with anyone you know it wasn't
about she was mine
she wasn't there for anyone else was
just my mom
you know what i mean and that's the way
i planned to keep it
you know i mean um i've i've explained
what she meant to us in that video
and how much i love her i always will
and i miss her every [ __ ] day bro but
um it's just one of those things where
i think that myself certain things i
think you draw the line
online you know you have to there has to
be some stuff that's for you and even if
i say
yeah my mom died and i loved her and she
meant the world it was
and i did try and give some ins and outs
of what my relationship was like with us
so that people could
feel how much feel the love you know
what i mean
um i didn't want to
give everything because
i don't know it's just too special for
me to to give everything do you know
what i mean like that and i think that's
one thing that some creators
could do with learning as well is like
what is how much value does something
has if you'll just share it with
everyone and
i do think you got to pick and choose
you know what i mean carefully because
once you give it there's no taking it
back
and that's the problem isn't it you know
what i mean with youtube
it's like once it's out there it's out
there so in that video you say
when you're you've i think you've just
been fighting with um
is it vlad's dad oh with vidals
and you i mean you've looks like you've
gone like 12 rounds with him or
something and you fall over and you're
back and
you get emotional because and he says
you know that's what boxing does it
brings
all those emotions out yeah and you said
a lie and you said i'm just a guy that
misses his mum
have you ever processed that
um yeah a lot a lot
uh i've truly faced
i know everything like about me that's
good bad i really face up to my
to everything in my life you know what i
mean i know where i've gone wrong i know
i i really faced things head on and and
with my mom
i i faced it more than anything because
it was
it was a constant in my it's like
losing a parent if you're especially if
it's a it's an if you're an only child
and there's only one parent
it's um so severe because it's like i
try to describe it to someone it was
like one day
i went outside and the whole world was
full of water
and people are swimming around in their
scuba gear or whatever going but what
everything's normal brian i'm like no no
you don't understand like
like the constants in my life have been
like the sun comes up in the morning i
breathe there
you know the moon comes out at night my
mom loves me those
four things like oh this is reality
so to remove one of those components it
blew my
[ __ ] mind like that she couldn't be
here anymore i was like
that doesn't make sense to me you know
what i mean so
i had to face it and i really have
processed it is
and i think that's why i never felt the
need to share it either because i was
like you know i'm
at peace with with that as hard as it is
it's just part of my life now and uh
and i and i feel like as
uh people say things like this but i
feel like she's there
i don't i don't need anything from
anyone to make me feel better because
when a mother loves a son the way my
mother loved me there's nothing anyone
can tell me in this world
about her about about me about us
so i don't need to share it you know
what i mean you said you had one parent
then
well my dad was you know around sort of
but like
in and out there you know he's like he's
a he was an old school guy my dad you
know like
like [ __ ] shagged around
went to prison just a wild man um
but i'm i'm i'm okay with my dad now i'm
i've just reached a place of like
understanding that my dad's got bipolar
disorder
he's uh he's never gonna be
quote normal like he's just that guy and
uh
you know he recently had a suicide
attempt which i had to phone the
ambulance for on that and it's like
what the [ __ ] hell is this like you
know what i mean you're panicking
um hoping he's gonna be all right he
then got sectioned again
um which this was this year you know and
you had to phone the ambulance yeah yeah
um
he texts me basically a sort of a
message that let me know what was going
down
you know so instantly got on the
ambulance and then you're panicking
because the ambulance
they're like oh kovid kovid i'm like you
[ __ ] just get there
like are you [ __ ] me two hours it
took them to get there you know
two [ __ ] hours and like it was like a
full-blown suicide attempt like the
pills were already gone
you know what i mean so um
yeah just like the it
it's stressful you know um when you when
you go through that and
it was i did a podcast about it because
you know
you don't really know what to do like
last time my dad was sectioned i was a
[ __ ] child
like so i'm now his next of kin i'm his
his parent now in this situation so he's
mentally unstable they're coming to me
asking me for the answers
i'm trying to run a company and and do
my youtube videos
hey everyone welcome back you know what
i mean
it's [ __ ] mental and that's one of
the weird things about uh
being a youtuber is like i know that
people rely on me for their escape
but it's sometimes that's why like you
you messaged me to do a podcast around
that time and i said mate
i ain't doing a [ __ ] podcast right
now i'm not in it and i didn't because i
just said i'll just be [ __ ] miserable
i mean great start anyway we're talking
about yeah
but yeah i i just knew i couldn't i
couldn't do it you know what i mean but
um
yeah it's been uh me my dada all right
like
he sometimes he just um
he says things from a different angle
because he's got bipolar so it's
it's challenging you know what i mean
get him to see where i'm coming from
sometimes
it's so difficult when eventually i
think a kid has to kind of forgive their
parents
and start parenting their parents it's
even kind of happened to me in a strange
way because i think
my mum i think my mom has bipolar dude
your mom's such a character i've heard a
few stories and i'm like
yeah i remember being young and being
told that well i mean the first one i
wrote
my book is when she came to the school
in her lingerie when i was like
four or five years old yeah because she
wanted to put on a show and then
the other instance that sticks my mind
there's one where she changed my dad to
the house with a knife and
the third one i remember is being told
that she had been locked up because
um they'd come to repossess her her
restaurant and she was stood in the
street with a knife and she was smashing
up her own shop
and there was police in the street and
everything and i was i didn't see that
but
yeah we'll have to set them up for a day
no but there is you get to a point where
you realize that i'm not going to have
the perfect family
yeah that i see in the films and i'm
going to have to forgive these people
who are meant to be my
idols and guardians for their own flaws
you know and
i just yeah it's i've made i've sort of
i've made peace with my dad's mistakes
in life
it's difficult though you know you you
know
it's a really long process of why don't
you love me why won't you be like this
why aren't you doing that why
you know and as the years go by you
realize
other people's parents are also [ __ ]
up you know
how many people can actually say they've
got two parents who love each other in a
great marriage and have been great
parents
most people i know don't have that
situation even if their parents are
together it's a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
so yeah people are on perfect and
um i think just accepting that is
a good start to life okay quick one one
of my best friends in the world
francesca sent me a text message this
week and i'm going to read it out to you
she said happy sunday so we're thinking
of joining the huel
hype i'm forgetting to eat all of the
time and i end up eating rubbish so i
need to sort out any recommendations to
start off with
and my response to her was any of the
ready to drink
fuels would be my suggestion whatever
flavor
you think is your preference honestly
francesca this is a very very good
health decision
and she then replied and said amazing
excited to get started on it
um and i think that demonstrates um the
genuine authentic relationship i have
with huel i genuinely
depend on huel um because i am prone to
missing meals and when i do have my
meals
sometimes they're not nutritionally
complete to say the least i'm definitely
not getting my vitamins
if i don't have fuel because a lot of
the food we have today is processed and
it's
it's filled with a lot of bad stuff so
huel has been a lifesaver of mine for
three years and
as i've said before it's such a joy to
have a sponsor that you genuinely
believe can help people change their
lives if they would only
start using the product so let's get
back to the podcast
anxiety is a really interesting topic
i've been involved in this mental health
company for some time now
a tie and i've just got really
fascinated about the concept of anxiety
oh it's [ __ ] horrible just
and i've experienced it as well i've
i've
oh yeah been there tell me about your
experience with anxiety
um and when and was it later in your
life that you first
uh i think the first time i'd had
anxiety was after my mom died
in the in the immediate i didn't know
what was going on i just remember being
in the room and saying to my mates
my chest is getting really tight i feel
like i'm struggling to breathe
and i was like uh and then
you know the doctors hired us some
volume and [ __ ] i think
i had that with some alcohol at the same
time
and that that was when the forcing
myself to sleep sort of
was was started but um as i got older
um i realized
uh through the youtube thing
just like being known
is is a really weird thing particularly
obviously around that time with the
the fall of true geordi as i called it
on the video
uh lot of anxiety and depression
um and it's just such a horrible feeling
to go through
because it feels very serious at the
time yeah but
it is in your head in it really
you've been very open about your and i
don't want to continue on this week
because we've got a lot
to talk about you've been very open
about your depression and suicidal
ideation
and one thing that i haven't quite
managed to
get over in your head is what you said
earlier where you said one of the things
that actually made you
hang in there was that people didn't
want you to hang in there
and that's the floor yeah yeah i i like
sort of there there was a there was a
tweet that was
tweeted at me it's such a weird little
confession uh where a guy went um
i've heard about your financial issues
or whatever he said in the street
and it couldn't have happened to a
better guy and
i've got like a dark sense of humor and
i sort of smirked at it
and i thought in my head i thought i
know i am not beaten
like i just know it and i and i know i'm
going to be rich
and i know shit's going to go come back
around so i just screenshotted tweet
and i'm thinking i'm going to use that
as like an air freshener on a ferrari
i have this like i don't know you know
what i mean like i
want to prove people wrong yeah and and
and i think that drive at the start was
a lot of that was like
when i started youtube so many people
like the [ __ ] is this idiot doing like
shouting on his camera and all that so
then all of a sudden there was that
that that negativity came in droves
[ __ ] thousands of tweets um
and yeah it was sort of a weird like oh
it's like starting the game again but
like on a different level
so i'm like okay now i'm [ __ ]
but i've been [ __ ] worse before so
it's kind of like
all right let's let's use this a bit so
but
to sort of uh
yeah the depression it's it's like it's
awful and it's so negative and you think
about like
i was thinking about suicide on a daily
basis at one point
i was you know i'm sorry if this is
bringing people down when they're
listening
um you know i was really seriously
contemplating it in
in a way of like here's what i would do
and and when the anxiety attacks were
coming over me it was just an awful way
of living and
i honestly don't know how i got through
what i got through like
looking back at it it was [ __ ] mental
um i've never been um to that point
so when i hear people talking about it
it just
it's like incomprehensible to me that
you could get to the point where you
think
the best route is to end your life
so yeah i mean
looking looking at it at the time i
thought i had what was like
situational depression where i'm in this
horrible situation
and that's why i'm depressed which was
partly true obviously
but i was also chemically depressed as
well like there was
what i now realize is
through that my mom dying other trauma
in my life
i definitely had chemical depression
like i needed i needed medication
you know um but um
i sort of um didn't believe in it didn't
want to do it didn't think it would work
uh for me you know and also like when
you're a guy who's
um lives in his head and thinks
you know i'm a small guy yada yada you
sort of
you're worried it's going to change the
way you think and make you a bit
what if it makes me dumber you know some
something silly like that or
you hear about other people's bad
experiences on it
like [ __ ] your libido all of this sort
of weird [ __ ] put away on you
there's this all sorts of little fears
so
um it had to get so bad uh before i
would
try medication but like one day it got
bad enough where i was like
i i realized i thought i'm definitely
going to do it soon otherwise
um i'm gonna have to i was like
frightened
almost like as a kind of like as a
friend of me
if that makes sense like i was
frightened for me because i was like
you're really gonna [ __ ] do this here
soon like uh
the way i was thinking in the way my
life was going and the way i was feeling
about small things that really are like
you know when people sort of push your
buttons a little bit yeah the way that
was making me feel was
awful like i was shouting at my friends
and my crew
and um when someone was challenging me
in any way
the the fear and anxiety was bubbling
underneath it was just overwhelming and
i had like really bad nightmares and i'd
wake up in the morning
and i remember just waking up one
morning just being like oh i really
don't want to live anymore and that was
when i was like
on the phone to the doctor and i was
like give us whatever the [ __ ] you've
got
because i'm willing to try anything now
and uh
thank [ __ ] you know um so they uh
they prescribed us some antidepressants
and i'm really [ __ ] glad i tried the
mitt honestly
you called the doctor yourself one night
one morning
uh it was in the morning night you woke
up and thought i need to call
yeah i just knew i thought i'm like
i'm i'm a liability to myself here and
it was like the fear of
oh [ __ ] you're getting dangerously close
like you like thoughts become things
right so like we we know that because
when we challenge our
channel our brains in an ambitious way
we can
make magic happen but also
if i'm thinking negatively i can go to
the worst possible place
and i really knew i was like almost
manifesting it because it
i was spending some i would there was so
many times it would pass through my head
if
oh well i'll just kill myself oh well
i'll just kill myself oh like if this
doesn't happen if this doesn't happen if
this doesn't happen it was
it was becoming an answer it was
becoming a solution
to all of the problems that felt like
they were mounting on my shoulders and
stuff like that
um so yeah um
and when i took the medication that was
when it really dawned on me like
oh that wasn't just because of what i've
been through or it was a
it was yeah post-traumatic stress
disorder and all sorts of other [ __ ] but
it was also like a chemical imbalance
probably in the brain where
my serotonin levels were real low
um and you know i was desperate
so i'm glad i took them i never see
you meditate go on holiday
relax chill out go to the jungle i was
in the jungle and you you messaged me
and said
i need a little bit of that yeah i mean
you look like you're having a a whale of
a [ __ ] time
um yeah but i am
on like a treadmill you know what i mean
like i'm not
quite at that point of um financial
um what i want from life financially i
haven't
quite clinched that moment of
will you haven't set yeah i will i will
you think so
yeah yeah because i don't think i have
um
[Music]
yeah but we're at different points you
know what i mean sort of like
um financially speaking um i'm nearly
there
i think i'm getting there i've got
a really good organized team now
money is is sorting itself out
and it's like if i just carry on the way
i'm going we'll be okay and then i can
have those moments where i go
now i'm going to rest i'm going to enjoy
myself but yeah i don't
i don't meditate i don't uh
you know how do you relax um
glass of wine and um i say a glass a
bottle away
but you know um will you ever talk how
to relax
no not really i feel like i don't really
rely
like the minute i put out something i'm
really happy with
i get this feeling of like content like
i'm like oh
that's class that that's a really good
piece of work that i'm really happy with
that but then like
10 minutes will go by and that'll be
when i'm like okay what we doing next
then you know what i mean and
i think like you know we have that in
common for sure and i no doubt that
when when i hit that point where i'm
financially secure
i'll still carry on being a bastard this
is it but
i will chill out more i will i will
chill out more and i'm already chilling
out more since i started the
antidepressants actually like in terms
of the way i behave
like all of those i'm so much more in
control of my
self now my anger my
ups and downs that you know they're
everything's a lot more relaxed and
and i communicate in a way that's not as
um
like you know there's times where people
have pissed me off and i would just not
even look at them
because i would be so frustrated that
when i tell them
i wouldn't i wouldn't even look at them
because i'd be like i want to punch you
right now so i'm not gonna look
you know i mean like i just exude anger
even when i was trying to hold it back
it was there obvious
and i don't want people who work with me
feel like they're working with a [ __ ]
lunatic you know what i mean so
the the antidepressants have been a
godsend and um
that's really helped me communicate and
now now if i have an issue
i just sit down and i'm just honest and
calm and i just go
he has what's gone wrong he has what i
think we should do better if you want to
hear
tell me what i need to do better i'm all
ears and it's like i'm a different
i'm a better person now you know still
not
the finished article by any means got
lots of work to do but
it just made me realize like my
and it goes by ironically to the trolls
you know even even the trolls you gave
me all that [ __ ]
it's like when you're really unhappy
within yourself
it comes out every way and and that was
really what was happening to me i was
like
and part of it actually made my youtube
videos good because like
the pain that like that fall of true
jordy video
uh it was just i just said lawrence you
need to [ __ ] sit down and i need to
sit down because i've got so much [ __ ] i
want to say right now
and if i don't get this out there i'm
going to [ __ ] explode
so we're doing this it wasn't thought
out or anything um
but it brings sometimes it's like that
struggling artist thing isn't it
people like that a little bit like to
feel like they're battling something so
it makes the videos better so it worked
in my favor a little bit
i just i've just come to i mean from my
own experiences i'm sure you've heard
this
heard me say this before just when i
when i was
insecure broke and striving to be rich
and successful
upon actually getting there i realized
that that was totally unfulfilling
because it just moves off into the
future and so when i what i think i've
come to learn maybe
is happiness is in fact finding peace
today irrespective of uncompleted goals
that's definitely in my head as well yes
that word peace today yeah like
in even in the last month actually i
remember thinking
i only want to be around people who are
who make me feel peaceful
if you bring drama if you bring aggro
stress
you can [ __ ] off because i'm trying to
turn over a new leaf now
and not deal like and i think a lot of
people just did not realize like well
they were keeping stuff on my plate
because i'm the mountain of a man who
can handle anything apparently
but i was at [ __ ] breaking point and
i just wasn't saying it you know
whereas now i'm saying it i'm like no
i'm not doing that
like you know the other day one of the
lads in the team
said it was um oh there was about
research or something like you know for
graphic design and stuff
and and me when it was um oh
it would help if you if you had a look
and i said would you rogan's team tell
them to do that
or do your own research joe you know and
and now i'm just very much like
here's the standards this is what we do
and
you know and are you still at do you
think this is what really what i'm
getting at here is
do you think you're still attaching some
happiness
to the future attainment of some goal or
and this is like this is scary it's it's
it's
it's healthy and aware because it's like
i'm not under the illusion that the
minute i hit the big number
that all of a sudden i'm gonna um
that will make me happy but the freedom
that that number will then give me
is what i'm looking for freedom from
what freedom
freedom of choice freedom to do whatever
i want with my life
right now i'm a slave to the game the
game for me right now is
i've got the all these shows all these
brands i'm trying to build i'm doing the
fighting i've got the kick off the
football brand i've got the podcast
and other things i'm working on as well
like my poker and
stuff and twitch i am on a treadmill
where every single week
i have to do i'm contracted to do this
show this show or the show i
i'm the most consistent youtuber in the
uk it's just nobody really realizes it
because
it's kind of always been that way i've
always been that the guy like even
though i slowed the podcast down
in terms of like the amount of videos
i've been putting now it's been insane
from
for years now um
so i i have to do them because i'm not
at a point of financial freedom
and even when i am i might still carry
on but it would be nice to have the
option to go
yeah i'm going to do this and yeah i'm
going to interview that guy here if i
want to interview a guy in america
i can stop the kick off because i just
don't want to do it this week or i'll
let my other boys do it and i'm going to
go to
early and interview joe rogan you know
i'd love to have the
i can't do that i'm chained to my
content and
i love my content fortunately and i love
the people i'm around
but if i if if i didn't it would be
really hard
yeah i've i've been thinking a ton about
this it's actually again the last
chapter in in
um in the book i was writing and i i
think my conclusion
my book's actually quite similar it's
called happy sexy geordie is it no
where'd you get the name no it's just
that last i was i
thought so much about ambition and my
conclusive point was when you realize
that you are enough and you actually
don't need more money or you don't need
more
external validation that foundation is
such a contradiction right
that when you realize that you're
actually you've got everything you need
then you
then the result is true ambition
not ambition to impress girls with a
lamborghini not ambition to prove
everyone wrong
but you go after the things that you
actually genuinely give a [ __ ] about
and when you get to the point where you
are you know that you're enough then you
start to go for
things just for the sake of like the
intrinsic content that's what i'm
talking about yeah that that's where i
am it's like
i know i want to get there but i'm not
there yet
and when when i get that big [ __ ] off
deal that's
insane then i can be like
i mean unfortunately that'll mean more
work but there you go right
but i'll have the money to then have
that in um
bring the plane into land eventually and
go okay now what do i want to do
um ultimately the funny thing is i'm
doing what i want to do now i'm just
doing a lot more of it than probably
physically i should be you know what i
mean it would be nice to have a bit more
bigger a bigger team is really what i'd
like to do is put
invest more into the team and have like
more people to help me because
me and the boys we do a lot it's funny
because it
feels like the snowball then gets bigger
as it's falling down yeah possibly
add five more people then that means
more brand obligations to pay for that
you know what it is though it would make
me so [ __ ] happy to be
um i i i know this is like i get why
this is [ __ ] but it's also like
it's enough for me
even people from newcastle have like
underestimated me even people who should
be
championing me and supporting me are
telling me i ain't [ __ ] so
just to like go beyond what anyone could
even imagine
it would be such a [ __ ] ride and
ultimately that's all i want to do at
the end just look back and go
[ __ ] me i showed those [ __ ] didn't know
like and
and have a good laugh and spend time
with my friends
make great videos that's what i want to
do what what are your ambitions now then
i don't think you've you know you've
signed this deal with um obviously jim
shark
which is great and you've you've done a
deal with beats which is great
you're over on twitch now poker stars as
well shut up
what is the big when you talk about that
big you know vision that you have in
your mind of where
you will be in five ten years from now
what is that
um i feel like i've
um i'm in a bit of a unique situation
in that i wanna kind of be the king of
multiple different things and uh
it's going to be interesting to see how
that that goes
uh i think i'm the best podcaster
currently
um about uh aside from joe rogan
no offense to your goodness i think
you're very good
um and uh you know i want to kill the
podcast game
but that's been something that i've had
to
uh in the in in the past when that [ __ ]
happened i kind of had to put that back
and go
where's the money going to come from and
sports is a lot easier to make money out
of
so i went full steam ed with a kick off
i think i've got something really
special with the kickoff
that to me is the the future of
football in terms of how people will
consume it in the uk that that show
the the brand the kickoff the the
personalities i've got there i'm working
on rebranding it right now
you know gillette's up a saturday's
dying of death i've seen it coming in my
life
uh sucker am is so [ __ ] like they've
all
piled like this what that happened in
that space right now
there's so many youtube channels they're
faking their views
they you i know them all they've got all
the big brands
budweiser you're getting robbed i'm just
saying that right now you want to check
the [ __ ] and
why why have certain youtube channels
switch the likes off switch the views
switch the comments off because they're
[ __ ] buying views and stuff like that
what we've got is so authentic and real
my studio i've spent hundreds of
thousands of pounds on the equipment in
there
we've we we've got something special
there so it's about watering it and
letting it grow and if i build the team
right i think we could like
no one can [ __ ] with us like everyone's
copying us everyone's copying the
kickoff
no one can copy the kickoff they're all
wasting their time all they do is make
us look better
their [ __ ] attempts that they kick off
make us look ten times
stronger so with that one i think we've
got something really special there
and i'm surprised a huge brand has not
seen that yet
like an amazon or or a google or whoever
the [ __ ] you know
because all right we swear on there but
we are killing it you know and
and credit twitch they did see it and
you know
i'm proud of that but the potential for
that brand i just think is enormous i
just
like i say i've been through so many
financial struggles while keeping that
going
i haven't really been in a had a chance
to put it in third gear yet
but i'm we're getting there um and then
there's the fighting
i feel like thanks to logan paul and ksi
they've put me in a really
particular position where i really know
fighting
but i also know the entertainment side
of fighting and
as as boxing moves towards that
direction and
mma as well and my history of loving
boxing and ufc
i can really nail down a special place
in that
where you know live stream wise
we're number one on fighting and
football
how weird is it that there's one guy in
the world who does a live stream on
football
and he's got the number one audience
aren't fighting
you know that alone puts me in a really
unique position
without having to talk about the podcast
where
it's ricky gervais one week it could be
kamaru uzman ufc champion the next
tyson fury logan paul do you think
you've got the credit you deserve
i definitely don't no why um
i don't know i don't know um
i think you know i just did an interview
for example with kamaru uzman
and the older i get and the wiser i get
him the better at questioning i get and
the
and the better i get as an interviewer
and leading
the the guest and and taking them on
that journey
my emotional compassionate side is
really another gear that i have that
other interviewers i just
you know i've always aspired to be like
joe rogan but joe rogan
has things i don't and i have things he
doesn't he knows
everything about everything this guy can
talk to anyone i just don't have that
but my emotional compassionate side my
empathy i think gives me something else
and on that on the interview i got so
many comments
because it was one of the first
interviews i've done
which was the same guest joe rogan had i
saw the comments and loads of people
going you didn't know
you [ __ ] out did joe rogan with that
one and i knew i did and i don't mean
that as a disrespect because he's like a
god to me but
on that one it really showed because
i just did a totally different interview
and um and i i'm
joe is always going to be the goat in me
but sometimes even the goat can be got
and i can get him every every now and
then and i and i'm
he's who i aspire to to be on every
podcast you know so
maybe i don't know i don't know what the
[ __ ] it's going to take um
i don't know if it's because i feel like
it's because i'm working class and i
don't necessarily
like some people just get credit thrown
at them like
mr beast wow you spent loads of money on
a video
uh what's the other [ __ ] who's always
surprised as friends because i don't
give a [ __ ]
like with all due respect you don't
impress me
none of you like you know your
creativity is bang average you know like
i could turn up with [ __ ] money and
buy a car for a friend
you know what i mean so i'm trying to
tell stories like with the fall of true
geordi with the rebuild with the
podcasts
though that content is like i poured my
heart and soul into it i edited it
with my uh edit a geo shout out to him
amazing
uh editor we sat together and did frame
by frame i do the grade
i [ __ ] everything like every minute
detail i care about
why does my podcast look different
everyone else because i care
and i will literally go and go right
we're going to do the grade we're going
to do
the sound that doesn't sound right and i
every [ __ ] detail i care about so
it frustrates me that i'm not where i
think i should be because the numbers
are there
the deals are there but the critical
acclaim
for whatever reason isn't there and i
guess it's because i swear and i'm not
like
mainstream worthy like i'm never i'm
never going to be
the kid who jonathan ross invites on or
you know i'm not and i don't want to i
don't give a [ __ ] about being well known
on telly
i don't want to go on it particularly um
and it's not because there's anything
wrong
with it it's just i'm happy where i am
you know
but um i don't know what it's going to
take bro do you feel like i've got to
move a [ __ ] mountain no i know i
i was just thinking about it then
because i agree with everything you said
in terms of the influence you have
and i and you i also agree that you are
the best podcast in this country and
really you were the
one of the real pioneers of a certain
style of podcasting but also on the
kickoff right you're a real pioneer
there but
from what i've learned about company
valuations and even how brands do deals
it's the way that it is packaged yeah
and
look i'm not greasing the wheels of
these companies and that's definitely a
thing i need to do better because
you talk about brand new channels yeah
certain youtube channels
will take people out for dinner they'll
schmooze they'll do all of that [ __ ]
and i'm clearly not doing that because
but like credit of the companies who
have invested in me because i've just
went look
i'm the best and and you know i learned
how to do decks myself
i was i've done decks i do all my own
decks you shouldn't be i
i sell uh well i've just hired a guy so
he's going to do them from now on but
the point is is like i got i've done all
right you know what
you've done really well i don't i'm
gonna say it
you're not getting the credit you
deserve yeah i'm and
and it's you know and you're not getting
the money you deserve either
it's [ __ ] frustrating bro like oh you
know i don't know what money you're
getting but i know
it's not what you deserve trust me bro
it ain't what i
no i'm credit to the partners we've got
because they've looked after us
um particularly um jim sharp and poker
stars
and twitch um i'm grateful for for those
people to be uh partnered with us but
yeah i i i definitely feel like where
where i am is not reflected
um but yeah i need to do the the
schmoozing [ __ ] a lot better
and and the deck side of things we've
built that out
and we're packaging up and branding wise
i need to be a bit more
there's a lot of rich old white dudes
who sign the [ __ ] checks who i need
to be
more friendly towards i i get that i
don't even think you do i think you need
a bunch of rich old white dudes to be
friendly with rich old white dudes yeah
i think you should probably call your
company
like true true entertainment yeah you
put it all under there the minute so
people when they look at something if
they if they value it as a youtube
channel
you're getting paid x if they value you
as a media company
a buzzfeed or a vice which i am yeah you
are
which i am but you're not you're not
packaged like that you're packaged as a
youtube channel
vice is worth five like i don't know no
it's what it was 1.5 billion
yeah like if you think about the
influence in reach you're probably up
there with advice
but you you're branded differently
you're branded as a youtube channel so
and i've done all this on a shoestring
as well bro exactly i've been
like i've been in debt for the tax man
i've got that rug pulled out from under
me with the deal i've had to scramble to
get other deals i had to pay off the
production company
all the money i owed them yeah you know
you know that one who kept us going
after the deal i had to pay them off and
then i went solo
and got my own production company set up
so we are
beginning which is the obviously the
concept
where the promotion with distribution we
are a [ __ ] media company
it's just [ __ ] frustrating because i
don't know who's dick i've gotta suck
they get [ __ ] respect around here
um but i'd i should be a multi-fucking
millionaire right now balling out of
control
i'm not balling out of control i should
be going back down to the [ __ ] audi
garage no
yeah i'm pissed off and i think that
chip on my shoulder is a healthy thing
in a way because it will just keep
driving me to get
that respect i deserve and ultimately to
get the money
to look after the people i care about
and
that's that's the goal it ain't about
like ultimately yes i've got an eagle
yes i want to be
respected yes but i could quit all that
as long as i get the money
to secure everyone who all my team
all of that you know what i mean and you
100 own your your
formats absolutely yeah i pulled up on
heineken because they used the kickoff
trademark and said i want my [ __ ]
money
really yeah shout out to heineken they
paid me off
yeah they used the kick off and um
i was like the kickoff the european
champions league night
uh on with heineken and i'm like what
the [ __ ]
uh tweeted them and uh and yeah i had
everyone [ __ ]
oh can we make this go away and but to
be fair
the gaffer at heineken was cool as [ __ ]
well he better have been
yeah you should sponsor the [ __ ]
kickoff
quick one as a serial entrepreneur
that's currently building
multiple projects across multiple
industries everything from the marketing
industry to
blockchain to consumer goods everything
one of the things that has been a
lifesaver for me and again a company
that i reached out to to evangelize
about on this podcast because i'm a
loyal customer
and they ultimately ended up sponsoring
this podcast is fiverr.com
r f-i-v-e-r-r what that site allows me
to do is extend my capacity
across all of my projects if i'm looking
for a graphic designer someone to
edit a video someone to do a website for
me
it allows me to extend my capacity
without hiring people and the quality of
freelancers on fiverr
has been amazing and when the the trust
and the service you get is that
phenomenal
and the services offered are that
diverse
it's a no-brainer whether you have one
member of staff
you're a freelancer yourself or a
thousand members of staff five it can be
a game changer for you and i'd love you
guys to check it out
use the link below go to fiverr.com
ceo and send me a screenshot if you end
up using the service
one of you is gonna win something very
amazing do you think you're happy now
i want to i want to answer this honestly
i'm really
really going there um
no i wouldn't say happy is the right
word
but i'm closer to in the middle than i
have been in a long time
you know what i mean like that neutral
point of like i'm not really happy but
i'm also not low
i'm i'm heading up to like okay
you know what i mean i have more okay
days than i have had
in a long time since i started taking my
antidepressants and stuff that's really
helped me sort of level out a bit
so yeah
i'm definitely a bit better but i
wouldn't say happy would be the right
word
and also i don't i'm not striving to be
happy
either i think i'm striving for peace
and content and um just uh
yeah you have your happy days you're
also gonna have your bad days but it's
like i wanna get to a place where i ride
the storm
and enjoy the good bits and appreciate
them and know that there will be hard
times again
but that are mentally equipped to deal
with them and then if i do have
a bad moment that i don't want to kill
myself or anything that's sort of my
what i'm looking for do you know what
it's going to work
what work it takes to get there do you
have any idea what it's going to take
yeah
yeah i i think so but also i'm kind of
think i'm one of those people that
i'm i'm not anticipating an easy ride in
life i'd be a fool after everything i've
been through to think
but now it's going to go great you know
so it's like
um that's kind of why i search for money
because i think money does solve a lot
of problems
and it can make life a lot easier and
it's it's not like
money isn't the answer but that can help
a lot
freedom it gives you yeah i'm still
super scared
conscious about my relationship with
money because i know
that there's nothing you can do to take
that kid out of me oh yeah it will never
leave me yeah they're still bitter me
man
i say a fast car and i'm like well [ __ ]
me yeah i can really go for one of them
right now
bitcoin was taken off i'm like oh should
i
should i get on the train do you know
what i mean once every three months i'll
send my friends one of them's over there
and my manager and my pa
a picture of a rolls-royce and i'll just
like should i do it
yeah yeah yeah yeah and i'll do it five
times a year
i'll never buy it but it's that kid
showing up again being like get
[ __ ] show them yeah and this all i've
tried to do in my life is just be way
more conscious of that kid in me
but but this is the thing is like at
this point for you everyone thinks
you're way more loaded than you probably
are anyways so it's gone to a point
where it's like
for you there's nothing left to prove
you've proven it you know what i mean
like you
you're and i guess yeah bro
credit to you by the way you've done a
[ __ ] good job yeah thank you
you're right are you yeah thank you very
appreciate it i hope you're proud of
yourself as well
um i am and
you're right i don't feel like i've got
a ton left to prove to people
and that's why that's what i was kind of
referring to and that for me has been a
really good place to actually realize
what i care about in life
because before it was all trying to get
laid trying to get girls trying to get
respect trying to get followers trying
to get whatever and when i was doing
that i was
getting i was making myself unhappy but
i was self-destructing when you finally
get to the point where you realize that
you are actually never going to be
internally worth more
you're never actually going to be more
valuable as a human being
no matter how much money i have my value
doesn't change
but insecurity is is is is it's a it's a
gift and a curse isn't it it's like
rocket fuel
it's like before when i was talking
about my podcast and how i'm underrated
you see the way i talk like the passion
whereas
joe rogan ain't [ __ ] talking like
that he's content
he is the king like he has nothing there
and and also
i kind of envy it because he's never
been that way he's never been
he's never come across as i need
validation
um and i i know that's in me you know
what i mean and it's not a healthy thing
and that do you think it's a good thing
it's certainly [ __ ] driven us so i
can't i can't hate it all
but it's like controlling it it's like
the beast inside you and it's like
um mastering it you know knowing when to
let it go
and like it's that same thing that will
make me obsess over
the quality of the content or you know
the detail or the
research or and it's the same thing that
when people let me down in a work
situation i get [ __ ] frustrated
because i'm like why the [ __ ] don't you
want this as bad as i do
you know what i mean but if they did
they'd be me you know what i mean
i'm i'm i'm me they're them but it's
it just strives as [ __ ] insane
sometimes you know
i think it's about balancing that thing
and as you say trying to master it
because
you're definitely right it was like the
[ __ ] rocket ship that took you here
yeah but at some point i think probably
to fly you've got to let go
and i genuinely think i've thought this
from just watching from afar and seeing
the similarities in me and you
i've thought to myself the day that
brian reaches his full potential
will be the day that he no longer gives
a [ __ ] about proving himself
to people because i think then i think
then how you operate becomes a lot more
healthy and
more more productive and more effective
you're not being driven by these
external forces you clearly you know
that don't want your best interest you
can be
in control because you're not in control
if if there's that driving you right
you're not actually i'm the same as i
said i'm on the treadmill bro and i'm
and the the day i don't need money
anymore
that's going to be a scary day for the
rest of the internet because
because the content's gone gonna [ __ ]
change like
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'll do but
it'll probably one
i don't know i don't i don't want to let
the fans down and i don't want to stop
doing what they
they love me for but i i am a person who
evolves constantly and i'm always
thinking
and reevaluating and what you know what
is this what am i doing why am i here
all of that and uh it'll be interesting
to see what happens then
i'm i'm excited to see if that if that
happens you know what i mean like what i
would say what i will do
you're relentless like um eddie hearn
[Music]
yeah yeah he's one of the most
relentless characters i've ever met and
he told me you know he's just working
for that day to sell his to sell matroom
and i asked him why he wants to sell
match him if it's making him happy and
he goes well we were never supposed to
be
here and it sounds a lot like what you
say to me and then he goes what i'm
going to do is i'm going to sell
matching 5 billion
then i'm going to go to the beach and
smoke my cigar and i said edina you're
not
no but yeah
i'm not trying to do that i i get that i
love what i do
and but like take take matroom for
example right
this is me going on a run again i look
at the zone i look at what matroom are
doing i'm like
you guys are [ __ ] geniuses this is
great why are you not coming for me
why what what are you waiting for ufc
are joe rogan i've got a [ __ ] huge
podcast audience
every video i do about fighting gets
loads of views my production quality
my shows um you know they've tried to
copy my show there's no offense but i
know they i mean i can say the way they
try to get a round table going they got
joella in there and stuff like that i
see what they're doing good good on them
like you know
it looked all right but we just come for
the real mccoy pays the money and i'll
i'll [ __ ]
i'll make you guys i'll help you out you
know what i mean
there might be an issue of being
dependent then on you right for brands
because if you're the main event
one day if you decide to yeah cut the
brand but look at what joe organ did
with the ufc
it was a perfect marriage his podcast
had the fighters on he told the stories
for the fighters
he helped promote them they then go back
in the ufc they're now more relevant
they get more pay-per-view buys and it's
it's a symbiotic relationship there
where you give me the fight you give me
anthony joshua the new anthony joshua
you need to build him up
and i tell the story better than he
could himself i helped make a
documentary on him better than he could
himself
i'm king of content and i'll help you
out with that like
i don't know i just feel like i've got
all these [ __ ] skills and i'm sitting
here
making my own stuff but like with a
budget
imagine what i made the rebuild me and
two other guys made the rebuild
like it was good but imagine if i
actually had a [ __ ]
netflix budget you know what i mean like
why don't you take investment then
uh i i would consider it but it would
have to be from the right person who
understood
what the goal was and actually backed me
but unfortunately because i've had those
previous issues where companies have
tried to
um get me to sign over my ip for [ __ ]
peanuts
um putting a gun to my head and [ __ ]
like that and i've had multiple people
try and do that
this made me very wary you know it would
have to be a big amount of money
and a good a good long-term partner
so you fancy it no i
genuinely i've always looked at what you
do and you know this anyway and i've
always thought that you
you had been undervalued and i tend to
believe that
and because you do you've been the king
of what you do for a long time not
blowing smoke up your ass you know this
anyway
no but you know it's true and um other
people who aren't as good because they
they're packaged
as these like big media companies
they're getting the big seven eight
figures
destroys his money yeah destroys us
i'm just gonna [ __ ] say when i
[ __ ] got a massive [ __ ] deal with
budweiser
or anyone we'll bleep that people
because they'll [ __ ] take me to court
um it destroys us because i'm just like
you guys are putting out [ __ ] content
you don't get any views randomly of your
video
one video's got ten thousand views the
next video's got five million no one
asked anything
no one like budweiser double checking
that like i didn't know and
and i'm sure there's some back
scratching going on behind closed doors
where someone went to eaton with his
other [ __ ] mate and i'm not
invited to these business dinners but if
you actually want to sell some [ __ ] and
you actually want to make a [ __ ] buzz
and you want to kick ass on the next
world cup or whatever
we we do the content we are
me and my team work so hard
it's not just me either you know i mean
we're all like
grafting constantly my editor for
example this kid works till like four in
the morning
[ __ ] regularly you know to to give
everything
and um and that's someone's gotta pay
for that one day like i gotta get my
end result from that you know we we do
because it won't i'm very loyal to them
and i and
we'll all deserve that do you know what
i mean that moment of look at what we've
built
you know when i see spotify signing um
they've just signed the girl in the uh
america yeah
uh call her daddy yeah right they give
her a [ __ ] huge contract i'm like
look at her views look what the [ __ ] am
i doing over here like i don't know what
it is man i don't know what it is
but i think i'm right when i say it's
because you've not packaged yourself as
a media company that you well
i think all her daddy had a lot of help
from bar stool
um and obviously boston being a huge
company in america they packaged her
well and
and put her on the map and stuff and
we've had to do ever like you
when you met me i was in a [ __ ] bomb
shelter bro i
i paid a toothless russian man 50 pounds
a day
for a sweaty bomb shelter because that's
all i could afford when when i met you
in 2017 because the company had sucked
me
a company had let me go because they
quote unquote
i'm not brandable and they couldn't make
money out of me because they couldn't
sell me properly
because of the way i was and i was on 50
quid a day paying
rent for the studio and that studio was
[ __ ] horrible
but now pokerstars beats by dre jim
shock and twitch
apparently think i'm marketable so i
proved that [ __ ] wrong didn't i
sometimes it does feel good to prove
people wrong steve
do you know what i mean but that's not
the goal the goal's the bank balance
yeah proving him wrong
when he said i wasn't sellable
i've competed with a company before when
i was in the bomb shelter
for for a sponsorship which was a
six-figure sponsorship deal
and they were a 20 million pound company
and i beat them
you know what i mean so to say i've come
up from nothing's the understatement of
the [ __ ] century and i just
um i need to get that point where i'm
content
like yourself i just hope and pray and i
think this is why
i keep you can hear me keep coming back
back to it is i just hope
that you don't believe too much in
you getting there and finally being
completely happy
okay i'm aware what you're saying yeah
and i've had plenty of money before and
i've i've had
the the adrenaline dump of bloody
driving a fast car and all that
you you you can live anywhere in the
world
you can drive any car in the world if
the people around you on who you want to
be around
if you yourself on content it doesn't
matter
because i wanted to kill myself in in
you know in a
in a situation where many people would
have felt like it was the
best thing and all of that and i i'm
aware of what you're saying
i just want it all i want the content
peaceful happiness nice people around me
and i want the money
and it's it's life's a good ride in it
so i might as well go for it
[Music]
i think it's possible do you know you
want to know something that's funny do
you know what during that um that week
of hell i had
i remember um i was just sat there i was
like
i think i was having a whiskey at the
time and uh this is what like a dark
sense of humor america i remember
thinking
hey this is so [ __ ] isn't it but what
a ride
like it was just a bit of me that was
like this is a [ __ ] story and that's
jesus something like you know what i
mean yeah you just gotta laugh and go
hey my life is not [ __ ] boring if
anything like
it was like you know
gotta laugh at it sometimes i'm new your
fitness stuff at the moment
i've been getting very into health and
fitness yeah i've seen that yeah you're
looking shredded
thank you bro thank you yeah i'm on
amanda's friends on his close friends
yeah yeah i say that i say the stories
other people don't say
as well how's that how's that um
impacted your life just having
you know you've started boxing and
you've started working out a lot and
you're looking good
yeah how's that how do i impact on your
mental health
it's be honest with me it's it's great
in terms of like
making you feel better and you have a
great workout and you get the
endorphins and stuff but also weirdly
there's the um if i have a bad week i
feel worse about it
like if i have like a week where i
haven't trained or i've put weight on
and stuff like that it makes me go
i'm letting myself down here you know
what i mean i need to [ __ ] sought
myself
supposed to be a gym shot athlete you
know what i mean like so now there's
more pressure on it if anything but
um are you gonna fight
you've gotta fight
i think i might do something like a
charity boxing match at some point
something that isn't like what the
youtubers do
i'd rather i
i'm i'm sparring quite a lot now and
i'm getting some like heavyweight
sparring in with like i'm going to get
some pros to spa with me and stuff like
that
and really push myself i feel like what
a lot of these youtube boys do is they
call someone out and then learn how to
fight
whereas i'm actually just learning how
to fight first because i enjoy it
and and also because i'm dedicated to
what i do like
if you look at my analysis on fighting
three four years ago when i did
logan paul ksi one or joe well like yes
i
and then look at what i can do now when
i break a fight down it is [ __ ]
so much better now and i think a lot of
the to be fair a lot of the boxing mma
fans although they they always disagree
with you
i think a lot of them are recognizing
like this guy is getting punched in the
head
just to learn fighting so he can do
better videos and that's real dedication
so
that's my actual goal to be better on
camera
but i do love fighting for whatever
reason it just brings out this
all the things about me that i've
probably showed in this podcast
or um that they come out in the in the
ring when you're
being challenged and wanting to quit but
keeping going anyway
like i think every entrepreneur has that
in them
really they're all fighters they're just
doing it in a different way
but when you're in a boxing ring it
really brings out you and
um it gives you some sort of self-worth
and self-esteem
because i i got that when i was at my
lowest point really my depression
um like all of a sudden it was like yeah
i am tough
so i'm not just a big lad i'm hard as
[ __ ] nails me you know and it
give me a lot of give me a good thing in
the in the time i really needed it so
if i was to do a fight it would probably
i'd rather do it like
a social club where everyone's getting
pissed drinking pints and a
live stream on my own channel or
something and and
donate everything to charity rather than
making it like
a spectacle yeah and i'd rather fight a
real
amateur fighter who i respect he
respects
no trash talk shake hands will have a
pint together afterwards
and you know just something like that
really you when you were going through
that depressed depressive period you
started boxing i noticed that you
stopped podcasting as much and you
talked about how that was to do with
money but i
was yeah it was also mental health yeah
i it's hard to do a two-hour podcast
even now i'm i'm in a much better place
now but it's still
it comes out we have to talk about it
because it was my state of mind and
obviously this is a podcast about my
life but
um when you're really rock bottom
i could get on and we do these uh comedy
videos for those who haven't seen them
called true news where we basically look
at the
the news and we just rip the piss out of
it
and um you know people like piers morgan
and the like they get they get a lot of
stick off us and um
i can do that because we can edit it
down it's it's me and laurence we're
laughing and joking
and then afterwards you know you you
switch off and
you go back to being normal when you're
podcasting there's really no way to hide
and that's what i love about podcasts
is like you really do get a good idea of
who someone is if they podcast regularly
it's hard to hide it's hard to pretend
you know and that's why i didn't do it
because i knew i couldn't lie
to the i didn't want to lie to the
audience i didn't want to
i'd rather come out and do like a month
later and when i'm feeling up to it and
tell them what i've been going through
so
for example when like i say like when my
mom died i never mentioned it or when
when my dad went through
um his um suicide attempt
i only did a podcast on it once i'd knew
he was all right and once
that moment had been and gone um
it's difficult when you're a podcast and
you're living a life
to to pretend like this isn't happening
to you
you also turned off all the comments on
your social media channels
yeah i just i was just thinking then i
was like yeah i realized i can't respond
to your tweets
or i can't reply to instagram you know
what
uh that's an interesting one isn't it
because it's something no youtuber
ever does because it's bad for
engagement and
i did that on a couple of youtube videos
as well and they still trended in the
top 10
in the world and i realized well that's
bollocks then
oh you need comments for engagement no
you don't actually
um and you know when you're watching
something on netflix you're not like i
need to comment on this
so why why is the comment such a big
deal but mainly
uh i got to a point where mentally i
realized
this wasn't helping me and for all
i get lovely comments and and shout out
to the fans you know you
they make us who we are the negative
ones were so
um nasty at times it made me just think
i don't need any of these and there's
that old [ __ ] poem
um is it rudyard kipling treat these two
imposters just the same you know
tre tre people who who who praise you
and people who criticize you i i just
thought
you can all keep your comments because
i'm going to do what i'm going to do
regardless to be honest with you you
your numbers
you're watching it cool but for my own
mental health
i don't want to hear it right watch it
enjoy it don't watch it don't enjoy it
vote with your fate
i don't need to read this stuff right
now because it ain't helping me
so uh you know a lot of people
even people on my team were like oh you
know you shouldn't do this shouldn't do
that and i was like bro
if you're going to sit and troll through
these troll through these comments and
delete them
all hours of the night cool but if
you're not i'm turning them off
and it's it's really helped me though
it's cause because because it's like i
put a tweet out
i put an instagram post out i put and
and
i'm not going what are the comments
saying well are they good are they bad
i just go [ __ ] it do you know what i
mean like the video is the video
and that's who i really am because i
truly i don't want to sound like it's a
weird thing to say i don't give a [ __ ]
but like i do give a [ __ ] in a way if
that makes sense like
i want you to enjoy it but if you don't
enjoy it
cool but if you're then going to try and
insult me for it or say anything bad
about me
i'm not interested you know what i mean
because i know i'm a good person
i know i look after the people around me
i know i've got a lot of
qualities and i don't need you guys
tearing me down right now so
that's sort of the way i look at it just
it's so it's so
one would say it was it's not surprising
to me because i think i've i've spent a
long time
talking to people on this topic but it
would be surprising to someone viewing
in
thinking you know true geordie big man
you know says he doesn't give a [ __ ]
swears down the camera all the time and
then
for him to be affected by the comments
on instagram
it feels like it feels it's not but it
feels like a contradiction
doesn't it just to to the outside person
who's viewing in
but then okay so to be absolutely
brutally honest then to really narrow it
down for someone who might think that
there is a contradiction it's like
um
i don't mind whether you like me or hate
me i'm actually fine with that
but if you insult me that will hurt my
feelings so i'm choosing not to listen
to either side
because i truly don't care if you like
me or hate me
you know what i mean i don't care i just
don't want to hear it because then i
will care
yeah and i don't want to have to do that
and that's the truth
you know what i mean and i'm comfortable
with that reality of
some people will like me some people
won't like me and i think to be as
honest i have from day one and just be
like [ __ ] it put out there like that
i'm not i'm not trying to make people
dislike me if anything i want to make
people
enjoy life forget about their problems
have a laugh
and it's probably as passionate as i've
come across here sometimes i'm really
like a lighthearted person and and
i think one of the main things people
say about me when they get to know me is
i'm actually really chilled out
off camera but when the camera comes on
i know it's time to [ __ ] do what i do
and it's like the volume goes up and the
opinions become
more powerful more passionate more in i
am definitive
you know what i mean and i don't know
that's just what i've learned to do
that's why i've come to learn about you
as well i think the first time i met you
i remember thinking god this is such a
such a soft um nice kind
gentlemen i am i am soft as [ __ ]
actually but then there's this
there's this exterior which is can be
quite
can be quite like aggressive at times
and itself
and it comes back to what we started the
podcast on really
is it's that two sides to me like and i
kind of called it my mom and my dad but
yeah very much so
like there's my mom's side of me which
makes me the care and compassionate
interviewer who
can pull things out of people i think
other people can't and make people feel
like it's okay to share that
and then there's the
arrogant show-off who
has a huge ego sometimes and uh that is
my dad's qualities you know coming out
with me and
um i'm i'm lucky
to have both of those you know because
it is such a weird combo
um but yeah i guess uh
is that it yeah that's it yeah no i
genuinely i've been fascinated by you
by you for so long and the more you've
shared and the more vulnerable you've
been online the more it's
it's all started to make sense to some
degree
and i'm i'm looking forward to see where
we go with it you know because i want to
dig
deeper i want to i want to i want to be
even more vulnerable i want to i want to
go further in the future but i got a gr
i like to grow as a person and then let
it come out
like in stages because you know like you
know how people like us we
sort of we're mulling things over on a
daily basis like who am i what am i
becoming is this the direction i want to
go
all these [ __ ] questions and when you
do that every single day and you're
laying a brick in the house that
eventually becomes
like the person you are in your life
three months to someone
like that is a lot they can do a lot
so yeah i feel like we can
i'm i'm looking forward to finding out
that direction
and and hopefully making a shitload of
money as i said
that's the if anyone any i know a lot of
investors listen to this
if you if you uh info art
do you know crazy i think crazy things
have happened from people that have
listened to this podcast so i know that
a certain big brand got a very big deal
off the back
oh really yeah yeah big probably worth
nine figures
no but you have you've really done me a
favor because you know we just for
anyone that's listening we had a guest
um move
and you didn't have to you know i mean
we're all very busy so i do honestly
appreciate it
i've always we've always got on all
right mate and um and i've always um
i like obsessive people who are pushing
themselves to the limit and uh
i i appreciate what you're doing and
you've always been respectful of the the
space that we're in
because i feel like you're trying to
bridge the gap a bit between mainstream
hence the tv show other stuff but also
the space that i come from
and uh you don't talk down to people who
are
on this side and i think there's a lot
of people who are in the mainstream who
sort of
they just don't know what the [ __ ] we're
doing over here and by the time they do
it'll be too late
and they'll be swallowed by this
industry so
i'm coming for your job i agree man i i
look at you as a businessman
and i genuinely and i'm sure a ton of
people watching this will as well i just
see and i've always you probably know
this
i've always seen a massive opportunity
because i do think what you do
represents the future and i also think
the way
you present your content and not having
the filter
also represents the future because the
reason we have watershed
and this and the bbc are so scared of
everything even though i'm now on the
bbc
is um uh is because
they is because of the medium in which
we deliver the content tv yeah if you
look at sky social media
they're trying to copy us every step of
the way now they
they're trying to do what we do you know
what i mean and and that's
a compliment and they're pulling
youtubers in from oh
all the time but when skye set up their
own version of the kickoff that was the
ultimate compliment
and when it went down in flames within
two years it was an even bigger
compliment we're going to end the
podcast here but we'll talk
we'll talk or talk offline about do you
know if there's anyway now i'm a free
agent maybe there's some way that i can
help you get the value that you've
oh man imagine you were the guy who
finally sold true geordi
to the mainstream and made it all happen
if you can do that
then you'll really prove yourself but
we'll leave that we'll
we'll let steve bartlett go and do his
dragon's den thing for now
okay but if you really want to see if
he's good can he sell true geordie
that sounds like a challenge i love how
he'll play with your regular yeah i know
yeah
just to see it you know me as well i'll
be going upstairs
now well done on the drugstore thank you
[Music]